[Music]
in the opening scene where Elise tries
to contact the dead when she's in the
bedroom with her brother she ends up
summoning a demon who appears in the bed
behind her for a fraction of a second
this appears to be a younger version of
the lipstick face demon who years later
becomes the driving force behind Lambert
haunting in the original insidious we
also see a small horse figurine in the
room which resembles the one found in
lipstick faces layer in the further
horses may just be a recurring element
in the further as we see them in Parker
cranes room as well
the Leeson Christian's room also have a
toy monkey which we also see in Parker's
room I have a theory on how Elise may
have allowed the Lambert incident to
begin due to her actions in the last key
which I'll get back to later on in this
video at least his father is often seen
plopped in front of the TV but if you
pay attention to what he's watching it
says a lot about his character first
he's seen watching and documentary about
Joseph Stalin and Marxism I never paid
much attention in history class but I do
know that Stalin was a communist
dictator back in the USSR and Marxism
was an ideology that was the basis for
communism if you think about it his
household is a communist dictatorship
where he is the dictator in fact when he
punishes Elysee the mother begs him not
to go hard on her but he says don't tell
me how to punish her i punish people for
a living
he also forces Elysee to ignore her
psychic gift and lie about the existence
of spirits in their house because she's
the only one with the ability and in
communism everything is controlled by
the state in this case her father and
everyone's contribution must be equal so
he tries to force at least to dumb
herself down so that she can't use the
power that her brother doesn't have
which isn't method used by communist
leaders to keep people in line and
prevent an uprising another one of the
programs he watches is Duck and Cover
which was a propaganda film shown as
schoolchildren in the 1950s it was
supposed to teach them what to do if a
nuclear attack hits but really was
created to give people a false sense of
security as not to raise panic I mean
come on this is an attack on Titan
covering your neck would not save you if
a bomb went off but in many ways Gerald
Rainier uses these tactics on his
daughter by forcing Elise
to ignore the presence of demons in her
household this way she stays quiet and
doesn't create hysteria with
her brother and her mom when these
presences are haunting them and Gerald
knows full well that these demons exist
and knows of their power because he's
been manipulated by the man with the
keys who forces him to keep these women
locked in in the basement and let's have
a closer look at this basement it's
filled with shelves of canned food and
you can spot a gas mask hanging on the
wall
maybe this basement is not just a
basement but also a fallout shelter
somewhere where you might go to protect
yourself from these communist attacks
something that probably works better
than Duck and Cover this shelter is
where it leases put when she defies her
father's orders
the gas mask could also be a reference
to how at least first learned to
communicate with the beings from the
further as we see here in the first
insidious when she goes back to the
basement as an adult the calendar still
reads September in 1953 maybe her father
never went back down there after losing
his wife so the fallout shelter comes to
represent a resistance against communism
in fact if you look back on major
historical events in September 1953 one
of the biggest stories was Communist
China being rejected from joining United
Nations at the request of another
communist nation the Soviet Union plus
Gerald's prison warden outfit is very
reminiscent of something you might see
on a Soviet General in World War two
there's a scene early on where we see
the silhouette of this jacket moving
around behind Elysee as she explores the
basement which is an early clue that her
father was involved with the
supernatural entities that that resided
there the house is located at four one
four apple tree Road in five Keys New
Mexico as mentioned when I talked about
the trailer it's a fictional location so
choices such as making this welcome sign
look like a tombstone our deliberate
it's kind of hinted that the whole town
is filled with malicious ghosts because
of the executions that take place at the
large prison facility which seems to be
the main feature of five keys one
character tells Elyse that she's lucky
to have gotten out of town and her niece
Imogen claims to have also seen these
spirits despite the fact that she never
actually visited the house at least grew
up in it seems like the whole town is
played by these occurrences and Lisa's
childhood home has the worst of it due
to the close proximity with the prison
the street address for one for Apple
Tree Road it could be a reference to
this being the fourth movie in the
franchise leading directly into the
first movie early on in the last key at
least mentions that she refuses to go
back into the further after a
Skol while helping out clean Brenner
which is a reference to her standoff
with the black bride in insidious
chapter three
this explains why she will no longer
astral project because she knows the
black bride will be there waiting for
her if she does this is why she's unable
to go into the further and guide Josh
when he goes to retrieve Dalton and
insidious in the last key her mother is
the one who saves her from the man with
the keys the experience gives her a
newfound respect for her mother so much
so that she refuses to take ownership of
the last name from that point forward no
mrs. Rainier as my mother just called me
Elise it's also where she discovered
that the further doesn't adhere to a
linear flow of time Elise meets and
gives advice to a younger version of
herself in the movie which would seem to
be the first experience she has with the
further bringing together timelines in
the real world there's evidence that she
knows about this in insidious the
further is a world far beyond our own
yet it's all around us a place without
time as we know it and it plays a much
bigger part in Chapter two when Josh
does the same thing he meets a younger
version of himself to help track down
the location of the black bride at the
end of insidious chapter 3
at least joins up with specs and Tucker
but mentions that if they're going to go
into business together they'll need to
dress nicer in this movie at least gives
them the new clothes which they
subsequently we're in insidious and
whenever they're on the job insidious
chapter 2 at least mentions that the
clothes were some of Jack's old outfits
Jack is her deceased husband whose image
can be seen in chapter 3 when the man
who can't breathe tries to trick her
into taking her life by pretending to be
jack sure enough the outfit he's wearing
in the scene matches up with the outfits
that Elise provides specs and Tucker
with which become part of their
signature look in the series going
forward it's not entirely clear how much
of Elise's father's behavior is just him
being evil and how much of it is due to
him being controlled by the man with the
keys but we do see evidence that the key
man's victims may have some control at
some point when Elise returns to the
house in 2010 after Ted Garza has moved
in most of the interior decorations are
the same but Garza has added some
religious symbols across on the wall and
many calm
of his Holy Bible which he expresses a
belief that it will help Elyse ward off
the bad spirits which seems to be more
like something out of the Exorcist than
insidious which is why it doesn't really
work there's also a nod to another
exorcism movie though Elise's dog
appears in both this film and the
previous film and his name is Warren
Eden Lorraine Warren are Elise's
ghost-hunting counterparts in the
conjuring franchise the other big four
film horror series started by James Wan
under the plum House banner Anna is the
woman being kept prisoner in the
basement when they find her you may
notice that she has a considerable
amount of leg hair suggesting that she's
been trapped down there for a very long
time when Elise goes to investigate
further she finds the suitcases of at
least four other women who have been
taken prisoner down there they each
contain information about the person and
their skull the one thing each victim
has in common is that they're all female
nurses it's never fully explained why
this key demon is only interested in
nurses but it does make me wonder if
this is somehow connected to Lorraine
Lambert Josh's mother in chapter 2 the
black bride first encounters Josh as a
child when he's waiting for his mom to
get off work at the hospital as a nurse
Parker Crane who ends up being the black
bride attacks Josh and it's discovered
that one day later he jumped off the
roof of the hospital killing himself
Lorraine finds this out after a creepy
elevator ride with parters ghost
Parker what are you you should be
resting you shouldn't be out of bed let
me know your thoughts about the whole
nurse thing in the comments earlier I
mentioned how I think it lease is
responsible for the red face demon
getting to Dalton Lambert in the first
movie it starts with these red doors
which we learned more about here in the
last key Elyse mentions that she
previously used a red door to go deeper
into the further she's talking about
Quinn runners apartment which is an
interesting case because the first time
she passes through it she's brought to
the Lambert's second house which she
hasn't even been to yet the second time
under the guide of one of the ghosts of
the apartment the same door takes her to
the abandoned fifth floor of the
apartment complex which is the home of
the man who can't breathe in insidious
Josh passes through a red door that gets
the lipstick face Demon Slayer and in
Chapter two josh elise and carl passed
through a red door to get to parker
cranes childhood room in the last key
there's another red door and it leads to
the penitentiary where the man with the
keys lives and this is where the final
showdown takes place so based on these
examples so far it looks like red doors
typically lead to the lair of the demon
who's haunting that area however it
would appear that there are certain
cases where a red door will take someone
to another time period and we see it
happen one more time when elise on her
way back to the real world in chapter 4
she stumbles upon the first lambert
house and sees dalton fall off the
ladder when she goes back through the
door she leaves it open and the dark
Moloch and demon who's been following
her all these years sees the chance to
go after Dalton and try to take over his
body to get back to the real world which
was his objective all along so in many
ways the key fingered demon despite
being defeated still accomplished his
goal he's been trying to get at least to
open all of these doors
ever since she was a child and she opens
the one that leads the lipsticks face
demon to Dalton the man with the keys
leaves all these keys around for at
least to open the doors but at the end
of the day the last key is Alise so then
the question becomes why do these doors
keep leading Alise back to the Lambert
family it could be the further or
someone in the further such as Elise's
mother trying to show that this is where
she meets her fate and it's hinted at
many times throughout the four films but
it doesn't do any good because the black
bride still ends up getting better of a
at the end of insidious and lipstick
face demon is still on the loose at the
end of the continuity that we've seen so
far so Leigh Whannell if you're watching
this it's been two movies since he gave
us that cliffhanger I think it's time in
Chapter five to tie this one up and give
us a sequel to Chapter two whenever that
chapter 5 trailer does drop you can bet
I'll be covering it until then remember
to subscribe the C's DS world for new
Horrors every week bring that deathbed
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive